Họng tắm dự nơi mẹ bà thằng chiến năng hành hủ trăm 20 năm
Công ăn tính đặc đá bắt được nắm đại thuật
Thương hỏi là học, 3 mấy tụi, 1 phương EA cao
Tính đặc đắc, y phạm rất hành hình mời trong cùng một gia đình ở đặc đắc
Thật bị bắt khi đặc mặc ảo chung nắng, chung ký mặt, lần chốn ở đường má thỉ lụ
Phương EA cao
Chứ đó, khoảng 2 dựa cùng này, tựa nha chỉ nguyễn thị kinh hát
3 mấy 2 tụi, 1 tổ dịch phố mời, phương thình nhất
Tại đây, thận dùng phương thỉ tình công lên tiếng vào các thình viên trong nhà chỉ khác hộ quả
Chí hát, 3 trình thị đe, 5 tự tuổi, mẹ chỉ khác, anh bối văn lượng, 2 niệm 3 tụi, mẹ chỉ khác, từ vòng
Châu chình tấn về, mẹ 3 tụi, có chai chỉ khác, bây tương nọc, sau khi về án, tự bỏ chốn
Thang người rất đe phương, tựa có quan hệ tình cảm với chỉ khác vào về xong chung nha
Có quan trung với chỉ này như chưa quế hỏi